on va terminer avec cette nouvelle qui
concerne l'association du droit au
logement à l'organiser une action
aujourd'hui à paris un rassemblement qui
a eu lieu rue de rome devant un immeuble
inoccupé depuis 20 ans selon
l'association qui défend les mal logés
et les sans logis
objectif dénoncer les vacances
spéculative alors que certains sont
obligés de dormir dans la rue d'habiter
dans des logements insalubres selon le
dal il y aurait 114 mille logements
vides à paris et serait plus de 3
millions en france
en fait ça c'est des immeubles à
spéculer qu'est-ce qu'il fait sa tribu
la racheter exane et puis là tant que ça
monte sa propre 4% par an ça fait
plusieurs millions dizaine 2010 qui
tombe chaque année et voilà c'est comme
ça
voilà c'est la pure spéculation cic
inadmissible alors qu'il ya encore 3500
personnes contre air france et comme
état dont l'arrêt il est inoccupé depuis
20 ans voilà c'est pas normal il vient
juste d'être faire les travaux à tout
neuf
sont ils des travaux sont que neuf c'est
la spéculation immobilière et depuis 20
ans il est vide
ça n'a pas de sens at il ya des gens
comparent logements sur la rue va on est
là pour l'été sur les expulsions des
familles de reloger les familles avec
des enfants m
les gens qui n ont pas d enfants voilà
il faut arrêter d'expulser les gens sans
relogement
certes les gens qui sont prioritaires
dalo et faut appliquer la loi dalo
voilà un pâle femmes et les ossètes loi
a paris il ya des logements vides depuis
des années et qu'il ya un problème
effectivement par rapport à des gens qui
cherchent des logements
et puis il ya des gens qui sont aussi
des heures dans la rue et au moment des
municipales
nous on est là pour mettre la pression
sur les maires des arrondissements où il
ya la spéculation qui prospère